David Boder: [In English] Wiesbaden, September the 26th, 1946. These are the last spools we are taking in Germany and they are about the last spools of the project. I am now interviewing Mr. Jack Matzner, forty-two years old, an important member of the Wiesbaden community, which is primarily supported by UNNRA, but lives in pri— is billeted in private homes. The billeting, of course, as I understand, is about 1.6 people per bedroom.
David Boder: [In German] Herr Matzner, wollen Sie mir nochmal sagen, wie heißen Sie und wo sind Sie geboren?
Jaques Matzner: Ich heiße Jaques Matzner und ich bin geboren in Wiesbaden. Meine Eltern sind polnischer Abstammung und ich hatte bis zum Jahre 1938 die polnische Staatsangehörigkeit.
David Boder: Sie haben die gehabt, obwohl Sie sind in Wiesbaden geboren?
Jaques Matzner: Trotzdem, dass ich in Wiesbaden geboren wurde.
David Boder: Nun wollen Sie mir dann jetzt sagen, was hat Ihnen passiert, dass Sie direkt als Konsequenzen des Hitler Regimes betrachten können.
Jaques Matzner: Vor allen Dingen wurde die geschäftliche Tätigkeit, die ich bis zum Jahre neunzehn hundert drei und dreißig (1933) ungestört ausüben konnte mit dem Tag des Hitler’s Übernahme der Macht vollkommen gestört.
David Boder: Also weiter.
Jaques Matzner: Neunzehn hundert acht und dreißig .(1938) wurden...
David Boder: Also was war ihr Geschäft, dass es schon 1933 gestört wurde?
Jaques Matzner: Ich hatte ein Textilwaren Versandgeschäft.
David Boder: Wohin haben Sie die Waren versandt?
Jaques Matzner: Innerhalb Deutschland, besonders Groß-Hessen, Rothenberg, Bayern und Baden.
David Boder: Ah hm. Also, das war, was wir sagen - ein Mail Order House?
Jaques Matzner: Ja, man hat es per Post bestellt und per Post verschickt. 1938 wurden die polnischen Juden deportiert. Eines Nachts kam die...
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter, bitte.
Jaques Matzner: Eines Nachts kam die Gestapo und wir mussten innerhalb zwanzig (20) Minuten das Haus verlassen. Mein Bruder, meine beiden Schwestern, die beiden Kinder der einen Schwester und ich selbst, wurden zwangsweise zur Polizei gebracht unter Zurücklassung unserer gesamten Habe und Gutes. Ein ziemlich großes Barvermögen in Geld und ein ziemlichgroßes Vermögen in Schmuck wurde uns abgenommen und wir betrachteten es damals als ein Glück, dass unsere beiden alten Eltern nicht mitgenommen wurden, weil sie durch ärztliche Atteste bescheinigt bekamen, dass sie für einen Transport unfähig seien. Wir wurden dann nach Polen deportiert—in Viehwagen, zusammengepfercht, sechzig (60) bis siebzig (70) Personen in einem Viehwagon—und kamen an einem Sabbat Morgen in Beuten an der oberschlesischen polnischen Grenze an.
David Boder: Wie heißt Beuten auf polnisch?
Jaques Matzner: Das ist die letzte Station in Deutschland vor der polnischen Grenze, zwischen Volten und Katovitz.
David Boder: Oh ja.
Jaques Matzner: Sosnovitz, Katovitz
David Boder: Das scheinen die Grenzstädte gewesen zu sein.
Jaques Matzner: Wir wurden dann teilweise durch die polnische Grenze geschleust und kamen dann an einem Sonntag im Katovitz am Hauptbahnhof an. Der Empfang von Juden, die in Polen schon davon unterrichtet waren, dass wir kämen, war derart gross und derart wunderbar, dass man eigentlich für den Augenblick das Leid, die Elend und die Not vergessen hatte. Aber...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie bei dem Empfang von den Juden? Was haben sie getan?
Jaques Matzner: Die Leute haben sich aufgeopfert. Tag und Nacht haben sie uns Verpflegung, Kleidung und alles Mögliche gebracht. Es darf nämlich nicht vergessen werden, dass wir nichts mitnehmen durften.
David Boder: Hat Sie Polen herein gelassen?
Jaques Matzner: Polen hat uns herein gelassen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jaques Matzner: Ich persönlich hatte allerdings noch in der selben Nacht eine telephonische Rücksprache mit dem Rabbiner Dr. Ansbacher, der hatte dafür zu sorgen, dass meinen beiden alten Eltern nichts geschieht und sie zu beruhigen, dass wir gut angekommen wären und ich habe versucht den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass es uns gut geht.
Jaques Matzner: Kurz danach, es war sechs (6) Wochen später, gelang es mir illegal aus Polen nach Wiesbaden zurück zu kommen und zwar mit der Absicht meine Eltern ebenfalls nach Polen zu bringen, weil...
David Boder: Das war in acht und dreißig (38)?
Jaques Matzner: Das war im Dezember acht und dreißig (38) und Jänner neun und dreißig (39).
David Boder: Also wann...wann hat Deutschland angefangen den Krieg mit Polen?
Jaques Matzner: Am ersten (1.) September neun und dreißig (39).
David Boder: Aha, also das war noch bevor dem Krieg?
Jaques Matzner: Das war etwa neun (9) oder zehn (10) Monate bevor dem Kriege.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jaques Matzner: Ich kam dann illegal nach Deutschland zurück.
David Boder: Haben Sie illegale Papiere gehabt?
Jaques Matzner: Nein. Ich habe mich geschmuggelt. Und zwar waren wir eine Gruppe von ein und dreißig (31) Personen, die beim Grenzüberschritt sogar angeschossen wurde, wobei das halb jährige Kind einer Frau erschossen wurde.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jaques Matzner: Ich kam nach...
David Boder: Was für eine Gruppe war das? Erzählen Sie mir bitte etwas darüber.
Jaques Matzner: Das waren alles Leute, die früher in Deutschland gelebt hatten. Polnische Juden, die mit dieser Aktion nach Polen deportiert worden sind.
David Boder: Und sie haben beschlossen trotzdem zurück zu gehen?
Jaques Matzner: Sie hatten beschlossen zurück zu gehen, um das, was sie hatten noch retten zu können.
David Boder: Aha,...und dann wieder nach Polen zurück.
Jaques Matzner: Und dann wieder nach Polen zurück zu gehen. Oder es bestand ja auch die illegale Immigration nach Belgien, nach Holland, nach Frankreich und nach Italien. Jedenfalls bei mir persönlich war der ausschlaggebende Grund: ich wollte meine Eltern retten.
David Boder: Oh ja.
Jaques Matzner: Ich kam dann illegal nach Wiesbaden zurück und wurde noch Zeuge der brennenden Synagogen in Leipzig, in Dresden, in Aschaffenburg, im Mainz, in Frankfurt und auch in Wiesbaden.
David Boder: Wann war das? War das nachdem dieser Mann in Frankreich ermordet wurde—das war Raat...
Jaques Matzner: Das war der, die Synagogen Verbrennungen in Deutschland, die wurden automatisch auf das Geschehen ausgelöst - auf Grund der Erschießung dieses Herrn Von Raat in der Pariser Gesandtschaft. Es wurde damals von dem damaligen Reichsminister Göbel—hm, die Sache wurde so präpariert, als wäre es eine Erschwerung gewesen, die den Juden zuzuschreiben wäre, und er hat den gut vorbereiteten Programm auf die jüdischen Synagogen und Tempel Deutschland’s ausgeführt, indem die Angehörigen der damaligen nazistischen Partei aufgefordert wurden, die Synagogen in Band zu stecken. Der Wiesbadener Tempel, der zu den sechs (6) schönsten Synagogen Deutschland’s gezählt hat.
David Boder: Ist das dieses Gebäude da?
Jaques Matzner: Nein, das ist nicht das Gebäude. Das ist ein Gebäude gewesen von dem man heute überhaupt nichts mehr sieht.
David Boder: Wurde es von den Bomben vernichtet?
Jaques Matzner: Nein es wurde durch die nazistischen Machthaber von damals vernichtet, wo es mit Petroleum und Benzin überschüttet wurde and dann angezündet wurde.
David Boder: Also...
Jaques Matzner: Die Synagoge, die jetzt hier ist, wurde damals nur deshalb nicht angezündet, weil die Nachbarschaft dadurch bedroht gewesen wäre. Es wurde die Synagoge nur inwendig vollkommen ausgeplündert und ausgeraubt. Die Sefer Torah’s wurden auf die Strasse hinaus geworfen, aufgerollt und auf dem Straßenpflaster. Mein alter Vater, der täglich in die Synagoge kam...
David Boder: In diese?
Jaques Matzner: In diese Synagoge—kam auch an diesem Morgen in die Synagoge um, wie gewöhnlich, dem Gottesdienst bei zu wohnen. Es waren nämlich immer noch Juden in Wiesbaden, die den Synagogendienst, den Gottesdienst abhalten wollten. Er wurde zurück gewiesen. Er erkannte, dass hier irgendwie eine Gefahr sei und ist zurück.
David Boder: Hm.
Jaques Matzner: Mein Vater selbst hat eine Sefer Torah noch gerettet, das ich nachher mit Hilfe meines Vaters in die Schweiz verschickt habe, wo es heute noch liegt und mit Hilfe des jetzt stationiert Kaplans William Darling von der Armee, werden wir diese Sefer Torah wieder nach Wiesbaden zurück bekommen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir zu der bevorstehenden Dedication dieser, wieder aufzubauenden Synagoge auch diese Sefer Torah wieder hier haben werden.
David Boder: Nun?
Jaques Matzner: Und so...
David Boder: Und was hat Ihnen passiert dann, wie Sie sind zurück gekommen?
Jaques Matzner: Ich bin zurück gekommen und im Juli neunzehn hundert neun und dreißig (1939) haben wir dann die Ausreise beschlossen und zwar illegal nach Belgien. Und zwar für meinen Vater, für meine Mutter und für mich. Illegal, weil zu dieser Zeit sind auch wieder von Polen zurück gekommen meine beiden Schwestern und deren beide Kinder. Auch für diese habe ich die illegale Ausreise nach Belgien - und zwar nach Antwerpen—vorbereitet. Es ist vielleicht für den Außenstehenden nicht sehr leicht zu erkennen, was das für Schwierigkeiten bedeutet hat, den „deutschen Boden“, wie es die Nazis genannt hatten, zu verlassen und zwar ohne Kontrolle. Erstens einmal die unerhörten Kosten, die dafür aufzuwenden waren. Zweitens mal, dass wir gar nichts mit nehmen durften, da man ja über die direkte Grenze fast kriechen musste. Auf allen Vieren musste man über die Grenze kriechen, aber man hat wenigstens sein Leben gerettet. Wir kamen dann etwa am neunten (9.) Juli neunzehn hundert neun und dreißig (1939) nach Antwerpen an. Wir wurden sehr gut aufgenommen von dem damaligen belgischen jüdischen Hilfs-Kommittee, wir hatten eine Wohnung und wir blieben in Ruhe in Antwerpen bis zum Pesach neunzehn hundert und vierzig (1940).
David Boder: Nun.
Jaques Matzner: Am zehnten (10.) Mai neunzehn hundert und vierzig (1940) hat Hitler den Überfall auf Belgien ausgeführt. In der Nacht begann das erste (1.) Bombardement und meine—inzwischen verstorbene Mutter—bat mich, dass ich nach Frankreich entfliehen sollte, damit ich wenigstens in Frankreich einen weiteren Weg für die zurück gebliebene Familie vorbereiten sollte. Ich hab dann...
David Boder: Den Teil der Familie, die in Holland waren?
Jaques Matzner: Wir waren inzwischen alle zusammen in Antwerpen.
David Boder: in Belgien.
Jaques Matzner: In Belgien.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Ich bin dann am vierzehnten (14.) Mai nach Frankreich gereist. Ich habe mich an dem Morgen von meinem Vater, meiner damals noch lebenden Mutter, meinen beiden Schwestern und ihren beiden Kindern verabschiedet und ich wusste nicht, dass es ein Abschied für das ganze Leben sein wird. Ich bin dann am sechs und zwanzigsten (26.) Juni nach Frankreich gekommen. Ich wurde einige Tage später durch die dortige Geheimpolizei verhaftet und zwar als Verdächtiger.
David Boder: Aber Hitler war ja noch nicht in Frankreich.
Jaques Matzner: Hitler war damals noch nicht in Frankreich, aber die einströmenden Flüchtlinge haben Frankreich vielleicht beunruhigt und so wurden alle Flüchtlinge, die kamen, als „suspekt“ - als verdächtig—betrachtet. Und so kam ich in das berüchtigte Straflager Le Vernie in Departement of Ariege. Ich musste dort elf (11) Monate verbringen und war mit etwa neun tausend (9000) Juden zusammen, die geflüchtet waren, unter anderem auch mit der, hm, Brigade international, die im spanischen Bürgerkrieg mit gekämpft hat. Alles in allem waren wir etwa zusammen neunzig tausend (90000) Gefangene, die hinter fünffachem Stacheldraht, unter schwerster Bewachung Tag und Nacht, Wochen und Monate zu verbringen hatten. Mein, in Frankreich lebender Bruder, der seit neunzehn hundert ein und dreißig (1931) in Frankreich lebt und dort einen sehr hohen Posten als Rabbiner, als Schlächter, als Dajin und als [unverständlich; vielleicht Moreh] in Straßburg bekleidet hatte, war während dieser Zeit nach dem Süden Frankreichs evakuiert worden. Mein Bruder stellte für mich ein Garantie das Zuzugsrecht in ein kleines Dorf, wo auch mein Bruder lebte, wo auch verschiedene Juden Straßburgs evakuiert worden waren und nur auf Betreiben meines Bruder’s wurde ich aus diesem Straflager entlassen. Es war an Purim neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941). Ich kam an dieses kleine Dorf...
David Boder: Also die Amerikaner waren damals noch nicht in dem Krieg?
Jaques Matzner: Die Amerikaner waren damals noch nicht in den Krieg eingetreten. Auch diese Zone, wo ich mich befand in Frankreich, war damals noch nicht von den Deutschen besetzt. Es war die sogenannte Zone „non-occupation“.
David Boder: Das heißt frei.
Jaques Matzner: Ja. Ich kam an Purim neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) nach Besancon. Ich wurde sehr schön empfangen und verbrachte dort eine kurze Zeit in Besancon und erhielt...
David Boder: Und Ihre Eltern?
Jaques Matzner: Meine Eltern waren...
David Boder: Sie sind zurück geblieben.
Jaques Matzner: Meine Eltern waren zu dieser Zeit immer noch in Belgien und zwar in Antwerpen. Ich hatte mit ihnen Korrespondenz und an Rosh Shoshana...nein, ich hab mich geirrt, an Sukkoth neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) erhielt ich die Nachricht über meine in der Schweiz lebenden Verwandten, dass meine gottselige Mutter an Rosh Hoshana in Antwerpen verstorben war. Ich glaubte...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Jaques Matzner: Ich hatte gestern [unverständlich]. Ich glaubte damals, dass ich es nicht überleben werde, denn meine Mutter, die für mich [weint] das wohlauf Bedeutsamste...ist ohne mich [weint und schluchzt] verstorben. Aber heute—nachdem ich fünf und fünfzig Monate im Konzentrationslager hinter mir habe und heute, nachdem ich die Gewissheit habe, dass mein Vater und meine beiden Schwestern und deren beide Kinder gewaltsam durch die Nazis von Belgien deportiert wurden, nach Auschwitz deportiert wurden und wahrscheinlich das Schicksal von Millionen mitgemacht haben, bin ich eigentlich beruhigt, dass meine Mutter damals in Antwerpen auf ihrem eigenen Bett, umgeben von ihren Kindern und Enkelkindern, gestorben ist. Ich selbst wurde am sechs und zwanzigsten (26.) August des gleichen Jahres nach Paris Drancy deportiert. Im Auftrag von...
David Boder: Von wo?
Jaques Matzner: Von Besancon im Süden Frankeichs, im Auftrag von...
David Boder: Warum?
Jaques Matzner: Im Auftrag der deutschen Gestapo, wurde ich von der französischen Garde mobil eines nachts verhaftet.
David Boder: Also obgleich es nicht okkupiertes Frankreich war, haben die Deutschen doch den Druck ausgeübt, dass man die Juden verhaften soll?
Jaques Matzner: Jawohl. Die Deutschen hatten ihre Finger bis an die spanische Grenze ausgestreckt und es wurden damals mit dem Transport drei und sechzig tausend (63,000) Juden, die aus Deutschland, aus Österreich, aus Ungarn, aus Holland, aus Belgien und von überall her geflüchtet waren, ebenso auch aus der besetzten Zone Frankreichs in das unbesetzte Frankreich geflüchtet waren, wurden damals drei und sechzig tausend (63000) Personen deportiert, konzentriert zuerst in Nixon, im Süden Frankeichs und dann in Viehwagen nach Paris Drancy gebracht. In Paris Drancy wurden wir sofort von der deutschen Gestapo übernommen und dort fand das erste Mal eine „Auswahl“ statt, die ich später in Kobel, in Gobelin und in Auschwitz, in Groß-Rosen und in Bergen-Belsen als „Selektion“ wieder kennenlernte. Auch ich wurde damals in die erste Selektion eingereiht und kam mit ein und achtzig (81) Personen zusammen in einen Viehwagen—Männer Frauen und Kinder, alt und jung...
David Boder: Woher wissen Sie die Nummer?
Jaques Matzner: Die Nummer wissen wir deshalb, weil eigentlich noch viel mehr in diesen Wagon hinein sollten. In diesen Einzelwagon sollten noch viel mehr Menschen hinein.
David Boder: Aber?
Jaques Matzner: Aber wir in unserem Wagon haben innerhalb von Minuten eine kleine Organisation geschaffen, dass ein sogenannter Wagon- Ältester sofort das Kommando übernommen hat, damit eine Ordnung im Wagon herrscht und er hat ein und achtzig (81) Personen abgezählt. Es war dies, mein später mit mir im Konzentrationslager zusammen gewesener Ludwig Lass aus Hamburg, der auch seine Frau und seine beiden Kinder verloren hat. Aus diesem Grund weiß ich, dass wir damals ein und achtzig (81) Personen im Wagon waren. Nachdem wir mit, hm, dem Fahren begonnen haben—der Wagon, ich muss das noch bemerken, wurde plombiert, verschlossen und versiegelt.
David Boder: Nun ja, warum hat die Gestapo diesen Wagon Ältesten gefolgt, dass man nicht mehr Leute rein?
Jaques Matzner: Wir haben geschrien und wir haben gedroht. Wir haben geschrien: „Wir sind ein und achtzig (81) Menschen, es geht nicht mehr, es geht nicht mehr.“ Mit Balken und mit Querbalken und mit Gewehren haben sie uns rein gestoßen mehr und noch mehr, aber es ging tatsächlich nicht mehr. Wir waren in unserem Wagon ein und achtzig (81), in anderen Wagons, die vielleicht etwas mehr Glück gehab haben, waren vielleicht nur fünf und siebzig (75). Es mögen aber auch schon fünf und achtzig (85) da gewesen sein. Jedenfalls war die Durchschnittszahl für jeden Wagon durchschnittlich achtzig (80).
David Boder: Ist—das waren die französischen , vierzig und acht (40 und 8) Wagons?
Jaques Matzner: Das waren die französischen Viehwagon, ja.
David Boder: Ja vierzig und acht (40 und 8).
Jaques Matzner: Ich weiß es nicht...
David Boder: Diese „vierzig Leute oder acht Pferde“ (40 und 8).
Jaques Matzner: Vierzig Personen oder acht...Ja, ja, das stimmt. [lacht etwas] Das stimmt. Quarante hommes ou huit chevaux.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Ja das war die Aufschrift, ja! Wir fuhren dann ungefähr fünf (5) Tage und fünf (5) Nächte ohne Unterbrechung, das heißt der Zug hat verschiedentlich angehalten, wir wussten aber niemals, wo wir uns befinden.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jaques Matzner: Wir bekamen keine Verpflegung, wir bekamen nicht einen Tropfen Wasser. In unserem Wagon war weder eine einzige hygienische Einrichtung oder irgend etwas, wo eine Mensch hätte seine Notbedurft hätte verrichten können. Wir selbst haben uns geholfen so weit wir konnten während der Fahrt bis Kosel. In Kosel hielt der Zug. Während dieser Zeit hatten wir neun (9) Tote, drei (3) Frauen—Wienerinnen, vier (4) Männer und zwei (2) Kinder. In Kosel hielt der Zug, wir mussten heraus und zwar nicht alle, sondern nur Männer von sechzehn (16) bis fünf und vierzig (45). Alle älteren Männer undüberhaupt alle Frauen mussten im Wagon bleiben.
David Boder: Waren Sie verheiratet?
Jaques Matzner: Ich war nicht verheiratet. Und ich war bei denen, die mit heraus gesprungen sind.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jaques Matzner: Heraus gesprungen ist übertrieben, denn wir konnten uns damals ja kaum noch bewegen. Ich habe noch genau in Erinnerung, dass während ich aus dem Wagon heraus kletterte, ein SS Mann vorbei lief, der folgende Worte sagte: „Wir werden Euch schon die Eier schleifen!“ Daraufhin sind wir in Gruppen aufgestellt worden und wir mussten sofort in Kniebeuge gehen. Es waren ungefähr neun hundert (900) Personen, die im Ganzen da auf einen kleinen Block, das war so ein kleines Karree, das gebildet wurde. Und von diesen Karrees sind ungefähr zwölf (12) oder fünfzehn (15) gebildet worden und in meinem waren neun hundert (900) Männer. Wir mussten sofort in Kniebeuge gehen.
David Boder: Was war das?
Jaques Matzner: Kniebeuge—das heißt wir mussten uns knien, aber nicht stehen und nicht sitzen, sondern die Kniebeuge. Das heißt die Knie so eingebogen, dass das Gesäß fast die Ferse vom Fuß berührt, aber wir konnten nicht...
David Boder: Und dann so bleiben.
Jaques Matzner: Ja, und so mussten wir sitzen bleiben. So mussten wir sitzen bleiben auf...nicht auf und nieder.
David Boder: Keine Gymnastik?
Jaques Matzner: Nein, keine Gymnastik
David Boder: Für was war das?
Jaques Matzner: Das war ausgesprochenen zur Qual der Menschen. Verschieden haben versucht sich einzelne Gepäckstücke, die sie gerettet hatten, unter zu legen, damit sie sitzen können, die bekamen sofort mit Fußtritten das Gepäck unterm Hintern weg gestoßen und wurden umgetreten und mussten dann wieder in Kniebeuge gehen. Und da sind wir etwa vierzig (40) Minuten. Nach vierzig (40) Minuten kam ein Auto angefahren. Es stieg aus ein SS Mann aus, der sehr viel Silber und Gold an der Brust hängen hatte und wir erkannten daraus, dass das irgendwie ein höheres Tier gewesen sein muss. Ich selbst hatte ja schon vorher fünf (5) Jahre in Deutschland gelebt und ich kannte ungefähr so die einzelnen Charchierungen der Leute. Also ich erkannte: ein SS/ Ober-Sturmführer oder Ober-Sturmbandführer. Und dieser Mensch, dessen Namen ich nach Jahren auch erfuhr, zog sich seine Handschuhe an...
David Boder: Was war der Namen?
Jaques Matzner: Der Name war Liepner.
David Boder: Wissen Sie, was mit ihm passiert ist?
Jaques Matzner: Ich hoffe, dass er erschlagen worden ist und ich glaube auch, dass er erschlagen worden ist.
David Boder: Von wem?
Jaques Matzner: Von den später durch die Alliierten Truppen befreiten Häftlingen.
David Boder: Ah so. Nun?
Jaques Matzner: Dieser Liepner zog sich seine Handschuhe an und machte zu seinem Adjutant eine Bemerkung, die wir natürlich nicht hören konnten, aber aus seiner Handbewegung erkannten wir, dass er etwas weg werfen wollte, so etwas Abruptes.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Und wir mussten darauf hin aufstehen und wurden auf Lastwagen verladen und sind ungefähr zwei (2) Stunden lang mit den Lastwagen gefahren worden bis wir in ein Lager eingeliefert wurden. Das war das Lager Name Gogolin in Ober Schlesien. In Gogolin wurden wir registriert, wir wurden eingetragen und am anderen Morgen wurden wir in Baracken eingegliedert. Während der Nacht mussten wir auf dem Hofe schlafen. Die Baracken waren aufnahmefähig für ungefähr fünf und dreißig (35) bis vierzig (40) Personen in Militärbetten, die zu dreien und über einander stehen. Ich wurde aber in eine Stube mit über achtzig (80) bis neunzig (90) Personen hinein gepfercht. Ich wurde...jede Stube musste einen Stuben Ältesten stellen und die Stuben Ältesten unterstanden dem Lager Ältesten. Das war ein System, dass wir damals noch gar nicht kannten. Wir würden hier auf Folgendes aufmerksam gemacht von dem damaligen Lager Ältesten. Das war auch ein Jude, ein Häftling, der schon frühere Zeit im Lagerverbracht hatte. Er sagte uns an diesem Morgen, bei dem Appell, Folgendes: „Ihr habt mit den Deutschen, mit dem deutschen Aufsichtspersonal gar nichts zu tun. Euer Aufsichtspersonal ist der Stuben Älteste, der Block Älteste und der Lager Älteste.“
David Boder: Das sind alles Juden?
Jaques Matzner: Das waren alles Juden. „Wenn Ihr was habt, meldet Euch bei Eurem Stuben Ältesten. Meldet Euch nicht so viel und macht Euch nicht auffällig. Redet nicht viel und tut was man Euch sagt. Redet nicht viel unter einander und versucht nichts zu tun, das gegen die Lagerhaltung verstößt. Hier redet man nicht viel, hier spricht man nicht viel. Hier kann jedem was geschehen, was er nicht will.“ Am anderen Morgen würden wir zur ersten Arbeit geführt. Es war damals eine Arbeit an der Reichs-Autobahn. Auf fünf (5) Häftlinge—ich betrachtete mich damals eigentlich noch nicht als Häftling...
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Also auf fünf (5) Personen kamen zwei (2) Wachposten. Die zwei Wachposten waren bewaffnet mit Gewehr, mit Pistole, mit einem kurzen Dolch und mit je einem Wachhund. Die Wachhunde sind ein Kapitel für sich, diese Wachunde sind eigentlich das Furchtbarste, was ich mir vorstellen kann. Diese Wachhunde sind direkt auf Menschen gezüchtet—und zwar auf Menschen, die keine Uniform tragen. Und es kommt mir fast so vor, als hätten diese Wachhunde—es ist natürlich lachhaft, was ich sage—aber es kam mir tatsächlich so vor, als wären die Wachhunde trainiert gewesen auf alles, was Jude ist.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir dies—um Gottes Willen, wie viele Wachhunde haben die gehabt? Sie sagen zwei (2) Wachhunde für jede fünf (5) Personen?
Jaques Matzner: Für jeden Wachposten war ein Wachhund da.
David Boder: Und wie viele Leute soll ein Wachposten betreuen?
Jaques Matzner: Hm, fünf (5) Personen hatten zwei (2) Wachposten, also hatten richtig gesehen fünf (5) Personen hatten zwei (2) Wachposten mit zwei (2) Wachhunden.
David Boder: Ja, und was waren die, deutsche Schäferhunde?
Jaques Matzner: Das waren deutsche Schäferhunde—meistenteils, es waren aber auch Bulldoggen darunter. Ich kann mich eigentlich nicht entsinnen deutsche Schäferhunde gesehen zu haben.
David Boder: Und die haben wirklich so viele Hunde gehabt? Es war ja eine Frage, wie man diese Hunde ernährt.
Jaques Matzner: In einem Lager, das ich später durch gehen musste, das war das Lager Groß-Rosen, das ist in der Nähe von Strigau, ein Lager mit einer Kapazität von neunzig tausend Häftlingen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Da war einen besonder Wachtruppe, die nur die Hunde betreut haben.
Jaques Matzner: Es war ein SS Oberscharführer und ein SS Unterscharführer und dann wieder so und so viel SS Leute, die nur speziell dafür da waren, dass die Hunde ihre Pflege, ihre Zucht und ihre Unterkunft und ihre wunderbare Verpflegung und alles haben. Wo sie die Verpflegung her genommen haben, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls, das war uns damals schon sicher, dass die Hunde eine bessere Verpflegung hatten als wir. Das steht sicher! Und die Hunde waren eben darauf, hm, hm, gezüchtet, dass jeder Fluchtversuch oder jeder Mensch, der hätte flüchten wollen, nach hundert (100) oder zweihundert (200) Metern sofort gefunden worden wäre. Und Flüchtlinge, Flüchtlinge, die in der Nacht geflüchtet sind, soweit das überhaupt möglich war, oder von den verschiedenen Baustellen, die wurden durch die Hunde mit ihrer Fährte verfolgt bis sie dann eben doch gefunden wurden. Es ist in den fünf und fünfzig (55) Monaten meiner Haftzeit niemals bekannt gewesen, dass es einem Häftling gelungen wäre zu flüchten. Er war einen Tag verschwunden er war vielleicht auch drei (3) oder vier (4) Tage und Nächte verschwunden, aber er kam immer zurück, lebend oder tot.
David Boder: Nun, zurück zu Ihrer Arbeit auf der Autobahn.
Jaques Matzner: Ja, die Arbeit bei der Autobahn war eigentlich für uns der Fügung nach sehr leicht. Warum, weil wir das Tempo, das später kam, noch nicht kannten. Wir bekamen eine Schaufel in die Hand gedrückt und wir mussten schaffen. Die Sinnlosigkeit der Arbeit ist uns aber gleich erschienen, denn wir mussten den Sand von links nach rechts und die Anderen von rechts nach links schaffen. Also die ganze Sache...
David Boder: Aber Sie waren dann nicht auf der Autobahn?
Jaques Matzner: Es war damals die Autobahn, die geschaffen werden sollte. Es war noch keine fertige Autobahn, es war die rohe Autobahn.
David Boder: Und warum sollten Sie dann unnütze Arbeit tun?
Jaques Matzner: Ja, der Sand musste geschaufelt werden, es war Trockensand und es war Nasssand, es war Getief und es waren Steine. Jeder hatte seine Arbeit und es erschien so, als wäre es vollkommen zwecklos.
David Boder: Es erschien Ihnen so, es war aber nicht?
Jaques Matzner: Wahrscheinlich war es doch nicht so.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Von Gogolin aus kamen wir nach ungefähr 14 Tagen in das Lager Fürstengrube, bei Katowitz. Es handelte sich damals um ein unter Wasser stehendes Bergwerk trocken zu legen und mit Fürstengrube beginnt ein Kapitel, das war vielleicht das traurigste Kapitel, das ich mit gemacht habe. Es war im November 1941, wie wir dort hin kamen und gleich von Anfang an spürten wir, hier ist Schluss mit allem. Die Bewachung war sehr streng, es waren SA Leute. Der Lagerführer, der dieses Kommando unter sich hatte, war ein gewisser Mareck und er hatte einen Assistenten, das war damals ein Polizei Wachtmeister Lapke, dem wir den Namen Messias gegeben haben, denn jeden Morgen um vier (4) Uhr war Appell, der begann so ungefähr um drei (3) Uhr und dauerte so ungefähr bis fünf (5), da mussten wir draußen im Hof stramm stehen und während dieser ein (1) oder zwei (2) Stunden hat dieser Wachtmeister Lapke jedesmal eine Rede gehalten in einem furchtbaren Ton. Man hat den Eindruck gehabt, dass der Mann...
David Boder: Hat es einen Lautsprecher gegeben.
Jaques Matzner: Nein, der ist von Gruppe zu Gruppe gegangen, der hat über den ganzen Hof geschrien, dass man es gehört hat und man hat immer den Eindruck gehabt, dass er besoffen ist. „Was glaubt Ihr wohl, dass Ihr hier hergekommen seid zur Erholung? Ihr werdet bald Euren Messias sehen. Ihr wollt ja nur Euren Messias sehen. Ihr kommt alle nach Jerusalem, aber nicht dahinten in das Jerusalem, was Ihr Euch erhofft. Ihr bleibt alle hier, hier gibt’s für Euch Jerusalem und Ihr werdet alle bald Euren Messias sehen.“ (Herr Matzner sagt das in einer komischen Stimme, er ahmt den Wachtmeister nach.) Und aus diesem Grund haben wir ihm den Namen Messias gegeben. Es war einer der Gefürchtesten, den es überhaupt gegeben hat. Und auch gleich am zweiten (2.) Tag nach unserer Einlieferung hat dieser Lapke einen Häftling, einen Herrn Lagro, einen Parfüm Fabrikanten aus Berlin, der auch nach Belgien geflüchtet war und auch von Belgien mit deportiert wurde, der auch in unserer Gruppe war, den hat dieser Lapke gleich am zweiten (2.) Tag erschossen.
David Boder: Persönlich?
Jaques Matzner: Persönlich erschossen. Und zwar hatte er ihn mit raus geführt auf die Baustelle, er hat ihm den Auftrag gegeben - wir haben genau gesehen wie’s zu ging—er hat ihm den Auftrag gegeben, dort im Wald etwas zu holen. Herr Lagro ist ungefähr dreißig (30) Meter in den Wald rein gegangen und dann hat’s geknallt und dann war Schluss.
David Boder: Ist der Lapke mit gegangen?
Jaques Matzner: Der Lapke ist mit gegangen, ja, und hat ihn von hinten erschossen und hat nachher hat es dann abends geheißen, Lagro, Häftling Lagro wurde wegen Fluchtversuch erschossen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jaques Matzner: Wir haben also gesehen wohin der Wind bläst. Dann hatten wir einen Lager Ältesten, der war ein Jude, er hieß Cohen, es war ein sehr feiner Junge. Der selbst war verzweifelt über die Lage der Leute für die er Verantwortung übernommen hatte. Und so kam der Winter—jeden Tag hatten wir Tote—erfroren, erschlagen und verhungert. Wir arbeiteten damals auf der Fürstengrube. Dort war ein Oberingenieur Reichmann, der sich so den Anschein gegeben hat, als wäre er der feine Mann, als wäre er der generöse Arbeitgeber, er wollte helfen und so weiter und so weiter. Dabei hat dieser Mann mit seinem Arbeitsauftreten die Häftlinge bis aufs Blut gepeinigt. Bei Nacht und Nebel, Tag und Nacht mussten wir draußen arbeiten. Wir hatten nichts zum Anziehen. Unsere Mäntel waren uns abgenommen worden und lagen im Magazin im Lager und wir durften sie nicht tragen.
David Boder: Warum?
Jaques Matzner: Weil wir in Bewegung bleiben sollten. Es hieß so: „Wenn es den Saujuden zu warm ist, dann schaffen sie nichts, sie dürfen keine Mäntel haben. Sie müssen sich durch Bewegung und durch Arbeit müssen sie sich Wärme schaffen.“ Und immer hat es beim Arbeiten geheißen: „Bewegung, Bewegung, Bewegung! Immer Bewegung, davai, davai, davai.“ Das waren meistens polnische Vorarbeiter, die uns immer so die Kommandos zugerufen haben und ich habe noch immer in Erinnerung dieses furchtbare „davai, davai, davei—immer Arbeit, immer Arbeit!“ Dann war dort ein oberschlesischer Werkmeister, der hieß Bielka. Dieser Mann, der hat mit seiner eigenen Hand jeden Tag Menschen erschlagen und zwar mit Schaufeln. Nicht diese langen Schaufeln, sondern kurze Spaten. Mit denen hat er jeden Tag Menschen geschlagen, die tatsächlich auch nachher an diesen Verletzungen gestorben sind. Ich selbst bin von diesem Bielka aufs Korn genommen worden und nur durch einen glücklichen Zufall kam ich in ein anderes Arbeitskommando und war so diesem Bielka aus den Augen gekommen, sonst hätte er mich zu Ende auch noch erschlagen.
David Boder: Wurden sie persönlich misshandelt?
Jaques Matzner: Ich wurde in diesem Lager dadurch, dass ich mich sehr willig gezeigt habe und mich zu jeder Arbeit sofort bereit erklärt habe, eigentlich im Lager selbst nie geschlagen. Und dann ist zu berücksichtigen, wir hatten einen jüdischen Lager Ältesten und als Jude, als Juden hatten wir dort einen gewissen Zusammenhalt. Wir wurden im Lager eigentlich wenig geschlagen. Nur wenn es tatsächlich disziplinarische Strafen gewesen sind, wegen Verstoß, die allen geschadet hätten. Geschlagen wurden wir nur auf der Baustelle und zwar nur von der SA und von den Vorarbeitern. Die Vorarbeiter waren meistens polnische oder schlesische Nichtjuden. Ich kann mich noch gut besinnen, wir bekamen einmal einen Auftrag ein Loch aus zu graben, um Telegraphen Masten einzusetzen. Zu dieser Arbeit wurden beordert ein holländischer Jude, namens Hammerschlag und noch drei andere Juden, Polen und ich; wir waren also fünf (5). Jetzt im Dezember, Januar einen Lehmboden, der bei einer oberschlesischen Kälte von dreißig (30) bis fünfzig (50) Grad härter wie Granit gefroren ist, da sollten wir das Loch ausgraben. Wir mussten es, es hat uns nichts geholfen. Und ich muss wirklich sagen, wir haben halb nackt gearbeitet, um es zu schaffen. Der Schweiß ist uns in Strömen runter geflossen und wir mussten es tun, wir mussten es [unverständlich; zu leise]. Und wir haben es getan, aber mit welchem Opfer. Von diesen fünf (5) Personen, die in diesem Loch gearbeitet haben, sind zwei (2) polnische Juden erfroren und auch dieser Hammerschlag, dieser holländische Jude. Ich selbst habe damals Erfrierungserscheinungen an den Füßen gehabt und ich selbst war einer dieser, der die Toten von der Baustelle mit in das Lager rein getragen haben. Ich werde nie vergessen den Eindruck, den ein Gesicht eines erfrorenen Menschen’s hat. Ich hatte den Eindruck, die Menschen lachen. Es ist eine, ein Übergang im Gesicht zu sehen, es ist das schon der Beginn der Agonie, die Menschen verzerren ihr Gesicht und es wirkt für den Außenstehenden genau so, als würde er lachen dieser Tote. Und dabei ist das der Tod des Erfrierens—und es ist dieser Ausdruck im Gesicht, als würden sie lachen. Und diese Toten mussten sofort begraben werden, denn wir hatten ja im Lager kein Krematorium. Das gab es ein Kommando, die mussten im nahe gelegenen Wald Gräber ausheben und es hat sich für die SS und die SA nicht gelohnt, dass sie für jeden Toten ein Grab ausheben, so wurden die Toten im Lager aufbewahrt bis so zehn (10), zwölf (12) oder fünfzehn (15) Tote immer zusammen waren. Das ha nie lang gedauert, das war innerhalb von fünf (5), sechs (6) Tagen geschehen. Dann wurden die fünfzehn (15) oder zehn (10) Toten hinaus gebracht und wurden dann—nackt, wie sie waren, schmutzig, verdreckt in einem furchtbarem Zustand—einfach in die Grube da rein geschmissen, zugedeckt, und so weiter, und so weiter. In der ersten Zeit war es uns noch erlaubt Kadesh zu sagen, wenn wir die Toten rein geworfen haben. Später hat dann so ein alter Schlomberg, Schlomberg nannten wir die schlesischen Vorarbeiter und Wachposten, hat das so ein alter Schlomberg verboten. „Was redet Ihr denn da für einen Schmarren? Das gibts nicht, macht Eure Arbeit und weg, ab damit.“ Wir haben dann also,...wir waren in diesem Lager bis zum Ende des Sommers neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943) wurde das Lager aufgelöst. Es sollte nämlich für russische Kriegsgefangene benutzt werden. Und wir kamen in as Lager Grevitz. Grevitz liegt in der Nähe von Gleiwitz. Grevitz war eine alte Mühle, die niemals dazu fähig gewesen wäre Menschen auf zu nehmen. Es war eine Mühle mit Ratten, mit Mäusen, durchlöcherten Fußböden, hohen Sälen, die eigentlich für Mühlen eingerichtet waren. Wir wurden dort eingebracht. Wir haben zu fünft über einander gelegen.
David Boder: Was heißt zu fünft über einander?
Jaques Matzner: In Betten, so Gestelle waren es und da haben wir...
David Boder: Neben einander?
Jaques Matzner: Das ist eigentlich gar nicht zu sagen. Wir lagen neben einander, wie die Sardinen in einer Büchse.
David Boder: Also es war eine Leiste zum Schlafen sozusagen?
Jaques Matzner: Ja, es war eine Leiste und ungefähr achtzig (80) Zentimeter Höhe, die Zweite ungefähr ein (1) Meter fünfzig (50), die Dritte zwei (2) Meter fünfzig (50), die Vierte drei (3) Meter fünfzig (50) und die Fünfte wieder bei...
David Boder: (Unverständlich) waren sie separiert?
Jaques Matzner: Nein, es waren also Holzgestelle, Bretter.
David Boder: Pritschen.
Jaques Matzner: Ja, Pritschen, die waren belegt mit Stroh und wir lagen neben einander, lagen neben einander in einer Gesamtreihe von fünf Mann vielleicht innerhalb eines Balkens, so auf Gerüsten.
David Boder: Was für Balken?
Jaques Matzner: Balken, die das ganze Gebäude gestützt haben. Und zu fünft (5.) über einander, voller Läuse, voller Flöhe, voller Wanzen, furchtbare Zustände, das ist überhaupt nicht zu glauben, dass das Menschen das überhaupt überleben konnte. Um drei (3) Uhr in der Früh war das Wecken, um vier (4) Uhr war der Appell, der Appell hat gedauert bis fünf (5). Um fünf (5) Uhr war Ausmarsch, wir mussten ein, ein Viertel (1 ¼ ) Stunden bis zur Station marschieren. Dann wurden wir wieder in Viehwagen, in Viehwagon verladen, und mussten bis zur Baustelle fahren. Die Baustelle war in der berühmten Textil Weberei, Christian Berig in Oberlangen, Bilau. Wir haben auch gearbeitet in Reichenach in Schlesien in verschiedenen Webereien. Und so war eine Nacht und ein Tag. Wir haben gearbeitet bis fünf (5) Uhr abends—bis wir ins Lager zurück kamen war es neun (9) Uhr abends. Dann mussten wir uns schlagen bis wir unser Essen bekommen haben, weil die Menschen waren ausgefroren und waren ausgehungert und wir Menschen mussten Schlange stehen bis wir ein bisschen Suppe bekommen haben. Wassersuppe mit Rüben. Und bis sie ihre Suppe verschlungen hatten, mussten sie sich schon wieder in die Säle zum schlafen. Dort wurde das Stückchen Brot ausgegeben. Für acht (8), neun (9) oder zehn (10) Personen ein Laib, ein zwei (2)Pfund Brot. Und bis alles ausgegeben war, war es schon elf (11) oder (12) Uhr abends. Und um drei (3) Uhr wurde schon wieder geweckt. Jeden Tag hatten wir Tote. Es war ein Zustand, der unerträglich gewesen ist. Und nur dadurch, dass ich mit dem damaligen Lager Ältesten, ein gewisser Zehngut aus Sosnovitz sehr gut befreundet war, hm, hat er mich in einen Arbeitstransport eingegliedert, der nach Hirschberg in Oberschlesien ging. In Hirschberg angekommen—wir waren damals drei und dreißig (33) Mann—wie ich im November neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943) nach Schlesien gingen, wir kamen nach Hirschberg kam, dort war ich in den Fricks Werken.
David Boder: Was waren diese Werke?
Jaques Matzner: Fricks Werke, die haben Wolle, hm, aus Holz hergestellt.
David Boder: War das wirklich möglich?
Jaques Matzner: Das war möglich. Aber ich will natürlich kein Urteil über die Qualität dieser Wolle geben. Es wurde aber tatsächlich Wolle aus Holz gemacht
David Boder: War es möglich daraus Stoffe zu machen?
Jaques Matzner: Das auch. Es wurden nachher Kleiderstücke, Uniformen, also Stoffe gemacht, also Wolle, die dazu zu verwenden war, Kleidung zu [unverständlich]. Von Hirschberg aus kam ich dann...in Hirschberg wurde ich eines nachts geweckt und wurde aufs Büro gerufen. Vor mir stand der Allgewaltige dieses Lagers, der SS Oberscharführer Weigel. Und er fragte mich: „Bist Du Deutscher?“ Da sagte ich: „Jawohl, Herr Oberscharführer“. Dann fragte er :“Kannst Du schreiben?“ Und da sagte ich: „Jawohl, Herr Oberscharführer“. „Na, kannst Du Maschine schreiben?“ „Jawohl, Herr Oberscharführer“. „Setz Dich mal hin, mach mal eine Probe.“ Und dann hat er mich an die Maschine gesetzt und ich musste etwas schreiben, was er mir diktiert hat.
David Boder: Konnten Sie das?
Jaques Matzner: Ich konnte Maschine schreiben. Und dann sagte er zu den anwesenden Lager Ältesten und zu den verschiedenen anderen Anwesenden, die da in der Nacht anwesend waren, es war ja zwei Uhr—„Ich glaube, der ist gut. Ich glaube, den nehmen wir.“ (Lärm im Tonband—klingt als ob es abreißt)
David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 164. This is Spool 164. This is Spool 164 of Jack Matzner and Anna Kaletski. There is quite some defective wire...empty wire...but this is Spool 164
David Boder: This is the...This is the...This is the Maztner and Anna Kaletska original spool, number 164. I’ve simply attached about a minute of wire at the beginning and at the end so that the actual original text be well-protected. Run about a minute and the text begins.
David Boder: Wiesbaden, September the 26th...spools that we are taking in Germany. I am here in the eh...rehabilitative synagogue, not the main synagogue of München, but that was the eh...second shul, so to say. And Mr. Jack Matzner is continuing his story from Spool 163. Hm, we are rather under pressure but I don’t want him to hurry, I want him to be as specific and detailed.
David Boder: [In German] Also bleiben Sie bei den Einzelheiten, wie sie waren.
Jaques Matzner: Jawohl.
David Boder: Aber halten Sie die Linie immer bei Ihren persönlichen Erlebnissen, [unverständlich]
Jaques Matzner: Jawohl. Ich wurde dann für gut gefunden, als Schreiber abkommandiert zu werden. Der Lager Älteste sagte mir nachher, dass ich ein Glück hatte: „Das kann Dein Glück sein“. In derselben Nacht wurde ich eingekleidet, das heißt ich wurde sauber angezogen. Bis dahin hatten wir ja nur Lumpen. Und in der Früh, etwa gegen vier (4) Uhr musste ich in Begleitung eben dieses selben Oberscharführer’s Weigel weg fahren. Wir fuhren dann bis zur Bahnstation Striegau in Oberschlesien und von dort ging es zu Fuß. Wir gingen und da sagte mir unterwegs der Oberscharführer in seinem Sudetendeutschen Dialekt: „Darfst mi fein net blamiern, wen ma hin kommen. Steh und dass’d nix redst, wenn nix gfragt wird. Und dass Dei Maul haltst“. Ich habe nie den Namen Groß-Rosen gesehen, da bin ich innerlich schon erblasst. Ich wurde eingeliefert und es ging nachher folgendermaßen vor sich: Ich wurde in Häftlingskleidung gesteckt, die blau-weiß gestreifte Kleidung. Ich bekam die Nummer zwanzig zwei hundert eins (20 201). Mittlerweile waren noch von verschiedenen anderen Lagern vier und zwanzig (24) Juden eingeliefert worden und einige Tage später wurden wir abkommandiert in das Lager Wüstegiersdorf, ebenfalls in Oberschlesien. In Wüstegiersdorf wurden wir übernommen von dem Haupt Sturmführer Lüdkemeier. Dieser Lüdkemeier hat uns einen Vortrag gehalten, dass wir also jetzt die Lager zu schaffen, zu errichten hätten und dass jedes Vergehen, das uns unterlaufen würde, unweigerlich mit dem sofortigen Tod bestraft wird. Wir sollten aus unserer Mitte dann einen Lager Ältesten wählen, der die Verantwortung für das ganze Lager hätte und dann wurden wir abkommandiert nach dem Lager Wolfsberg. Wolfsberg das war einfach eine...eine freie Fläche von Berg und Tal—eine kahle Fläche und wir sollten da ein Lager bauen. Wir bekamen das Material und am anderen Tag oder zwei (2) Tage später kamen schon die ersten acht tausend (8000) ungarischen und griechischen Juden an; und zwar kamen die aus Auschwitz. Diese Juden wurden sofort empfangen, sie waren alle tätowiert und sie mussten das Lager aufbauen mit dem Material, das wir hatten und in kurzer Zeit stand auch das Lager da. Es war in keinem Block, sondern es waren solche runde Eskimo Zelte. Wir nannten sie die Finnen Zelte.
Jaques Matzner: Im Laufe einer kurzen Zeit hatten wir einen Belegschaft von ungefähr ein und zwanzig tausend (21000) Personen, alles Juden: Rabbiner, Shohet (Schlächter), Rabbeien, Chasidim, Handwerker, [unverständlich]-Arbeiter, Oberstaatsanwälte, Arbeiter, Polen, Ungarn, Rumänen, Deutsche, Franzosen, Griechen—ein ganz internationales Gemisch von Menschen. Aber trotz dessen, dass wir Führenden uns vorgenommen hatten, zusammen zu halten und jedem einzelnen Menschen zu helfen, zu retten—haben wir einfach das damals geschaffene Krankenrevier, das von dem ungarischen Arzt Doktor Frieck und Doktor Deutsch geleitet wurde, da haben wir alle Kranken und alle Rabbeien und alle Rabbiner, alle Verschiedenen haben wir dort rein gelegt, auch wenn die nicht krank waren. Nur damit wir diese Menschen, die doch niemals gearbeitet haben, vor der schweren Arbeit zu schützen. Es wurde nämlich ein Tunnel gebaut von einer Länge von zirka fünf und dreißig (35) bis vierzig (40) Kilometer und den mussten wir bauen. Jeden Tag hatten wir Tote. Bauverletzungen, Einstürze, die Baggermaschinen haben jeden Tag Menschen erschlagen, die Meister haben geschlagen, wir haben gewusst es geht hier auf Leben und Tod. Und nur dadurch, dass wir eine eigene gute Organisation geschaffen hatten, wurde es verhindert, dass im Lager selbst nie etwas vorkam, das gegen unsere Bestrebungen gegangen wäre. In diesem Lager haben wir verbracht bis zum Januar neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945). Im Januar neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945) wurde das Lager geräumt. Wir wussten schon warum, denn wir hatten in dieser Zeit schon unsere Fühler und unsere Ohren nach außen hin ausgestreckt. Wir wussten die Russen sind im Anzug. Wir haben jede Nacht gesehen, wie Breslau bombardiert worden ist. Wir haben über unser Lager alliierte Flugzeuge fliegen gesehen, die genau wussten, dass die Menschen, die da unten sind in den blau weißen Uniformen, dass das eigene Menschen sind und dass keinen Bomben abgeworfen werden. Breslau wurde bombardiert. Bleiwitz und Leibnitz wurden bombardiert, in unserer Nähe sind Bomben gefallen, aber das Lager wurde nie bombardiert, weil unsere Brüder in der Luft wussten, hier unten sind unsere Jungs, hier unten sind eigene Menschen und wir sehen, dass ihnen nichts geschehe.
Jaques Matzner: Im Januar neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945) wurde das Lager aufgelöst und wir sind abmarschiert nach Schirmberg. Das waren alles so kleine Dörfer—Stationen, wo, hm, man uns aufnahm, bis wir in das große Lager Bergen-Belsen kamen. Unterwegs hatten wir nicht nur Dutzende, sondern Hunderte von Toten. Menschen, alt und krank und schwach, die den Marsch nicht überstehen konnten, sind an der Strasse liegen geblieben. Wir mussten sie mitschleppen und nachts begraben. Vorher wurden ihnen noch auf Anordnung der SS die Goldzähne ausgebrochen. Und dann ging’s immer weiter und immer weiter. Haufen und Berge von Leichen habe sich getürmt, die einfach irgendwo begraben und verscharrt worden sind. Und dann eines Nachts kamen wir in Bergen-Belsen an. Bergen-Belsen—das Lager, das wir eigentlich in seiner wahren Fratze erst gar nicht erkannt haben. Das sahen wir erst am Tag darauf, wir sahen, wie wir behandelt wurden. Alles abgeben, hin legen, stehen bleiben, stundenlange Appelle. Unter stundenlange Appelle ist zu verstehen sechzehn (16 und zwanzig (20) Stunden lange Appelle—in Dreck, in Schnee, in Eis, in Wasser. Jeden Tag hatten wir in den Barracken noch Menschen, die sich nachts hingelegt haben, sich schlafen legt, morgens waren sie tot. Im Dunkeln haben wir nicht gesehen, was in diesem überpferchten und überpfropften Block vor gegangen ist. Einer hat den Anderen erschlagen. Wir sahen vielleicht eine Ermassung von hundert tausend (100000) Menschen in diesem Lager. Christen und Juden, Katholiken und Protestanten, englische Soldaten, Fallschirmabspringer, französische Freiwillige, die sich gemeldet hatten, um auf alliierter Seite gegen die Deutschen zu kämpfen, Juden, Maquis waren da, alles war da und jeder hat gewusst, es geht um die Minute. In Bergen-Belsen habe ich das erste Mal gesehen, dass Menschen verbrannt wurden auf offenen Scheiterhaufen. Scheinbar hat das Gas oder die Gaszuleitung nicht funktioniert zu haben, da haben sie die Menschen aufgeschichtet in Haufen und haben sie - wahrscheinlich mit Benzin oder Petroleum überschüttet und haben sie verbrannt auf offenen Scheiterhaufen. Man hat sich an diesen Anblick gewöhnt—so, als wäre es etwas Alltägliches. Es ist fürchterlich so etwas auszusprechen. Und heute begreife ich nicht, wie ich diesen Gestank, der nicht nur durch die Nase ging, sondern der einem am Gaumen geklebt hat, als wäre es etwas Greifbares, Ekelhaftes, dass man diesen Gestank und diese bestialische Luft überstehen konnte.
Jaques Matzner: Und an diesem,...eines schöne Tages wird ein Arbeitstransport zusammen gestellt für irgend ein Lager. Wir wollten unter allen Umständen aus diesem Lager Bergen-Belsen heraus und haben uns gemeldet und es ist geglückt, es wurden ungefähr drei tausend (3000) Personen zusammen gestellt. Und wir sind dann los marschiert an die Bahn und mit der Bahn sind wir wieder fünf (5) Tage und fünf (5) Nächte langem Fahren nach Messantin gekommen. Messantin ist ein kleiner Platz in der Nähe von Frankfurt an der Oder oder von Stettin. Wir wussten ja nie, wo wir uns befanden. Jedenfalls haben wir damals gearbeitet in den Hydrierwerken in Pohlitz. Das ist ein Werk so gross, wie eine ganze Stadt. Es wurde dort her gestellt Benzin und Treibstoff. Ein Meister, unter dem ich arbeitete, der sagte mir mal, dass in diesem Werk, hm, täglich vier einhalb (4 ½ ) Millionen Liter Betriebsstoff hergestellt worden wären. Bis dann in einer Nacht einmal ein Raid von zwei tausend (2000) englischen und amerikanischen Flugzeugen in Wellen gekommen ist, die das ganze Werk innerhalb von einer oder zwei Stunden zerstört hätten. Jedenfalls wir mussten aufräumen. Wir mussten also die Trümmer weg räumen und die Schutthaufen weg räumen und es sollte immer weiter gearbeitet werden. Und inzwischen lagen wir schon in diesem Werk unter Artilleriebeschuss der Russen, die auf der anderen Seite der Oder standen. Unser Lager und unsere Arbeitsstätte war also diesseits der Oder und die Russen standen schon jenseits der Oder. Wir lagen dauernd unter Artilleriebeschuss und eines schönen Tages hatten wir sogar fünf- oder sechsundzwanzig Tote oder Verletzte, und darunter waren auch Wachtposten, die auch erschossen und erschlagen worden sind von Bomben und den Artilleriegeschossen der russischen Artillerie. Und dann wurde auch dieses Lager geräumt und wir kamen nach Barth. Barth ist eine kleine Stadt in der Nähe von Wismar und dort wurden wir untergebracht in den Heinkel Flugzeugwerken. Die Heinkel Flugzeugwerke sahen sehr schön aus. Das Lager war sehr schön, aber was dort vorgekommen ist, das spottet jeder Beschreibung.
David Boder: Wo war das?
Jaques Matzner: Das war in Barth in den Heinkel Flugzeugwerken. Ich habe gerade eben durch gesagt, dass ich Belege und alles durchgegangen bin.
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: Und dort spürte ich auch das erste Mal, dass ich anfing schwach zu werden. Ich konnte nicht mehr. Und, hm, mein Freund mit dem ich die ganze Zeit und die ganzen Jahre zusammen verbrachte, Fischel Wiener aus Sosnovitz, der sagte mir: „Matzner, halte Dich, halte Dich, sei stark, es kann nicht mehr lange dauern!“
David Boder: In welchem Jahre war das?
Jaques Matzner: Ds war im Jahre neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945).
David Boder: Ja.
Jaques Matzner: „Es muss noch gehen, Du hast so lange durch gehalten. Nun sei stark.“ Und dabei sind jeden Tag meine besten Freunde gefallen und gestorben. Mein besten Kameraden sind dabei zu Grunde gegangen. Ich war zusammen mit einem ungarischen Groß-Grundbesitzer Ludwig Biro aus Szatmár.
David Boder: Ein Jude?
Jaques Matzner: Ein Jude—er war mit seinem Bruder dort. Sein Bruder ist dort umgekommen, sein Bruder ist dort gestorben. Und wie die Menschen umgekommen sind. Einer meiner besten Freunde, Moishe Rotbart, hat sich dort selbst aufgehängt, ein frommer Mensch, der gesagt hat: „Ich kann nicht mehr! Ich kann nicht mehr!“ Bei der Arbeit hat er die Zähne zusammen gebissen. Er wollte es überleben, aber er konnte es nicht, er hat sich selbst das Leben genommen. Einen Tag später sah ich ihn unten im Keller als Leiche liegen. Und so waren jede Tag noch mehr Selbstmode und jeden Tag noch mehr Menschen erschlagen worden. Eines schönen Morgens verspürte ich, dass ich Fieber hatte. Ich hatte ja die ganze Zeit schon Fieber, aber an diesem Morgen war es besonders stark und ich ging ins Hospital, um mir das Fieber messen zu lassen und der Sanitäter maß neun und dreißig sechs (39.6) Fieber. Ich bin mit diesem Zettel, den er mir ausgestellt hatte, dass ich neun und dreißig sechs (39.6) Fieber habe zum Lager Ältesten gegangen und habe ihn gebeten mich im Lager liegen zu lassen, da ich ein so hohes Fieber hatte. Darauf gab er mir einen Tritt in den Leib.
David Boder: War das ein Jude?
Jaques Matzner: Das war ein Christ, ein sogenannte BVer war das, ein Berufsverbrecher. Da gab er mir einen Tritt in dem Leib und sagte: „Du Judensau, geh raus. Für Dich ist es schon längst Zeit, dass Du krepierst.“ Und durch den Tritt bin ich hin gefallen und bin am Boden liegen geblieben. Ich verspürte nur noch, dass ich in den Rücken und in das Gesicht getreten wurde. Und so bin ich liegen geblieben und als ich dann wieder zu mir kam—ich war bewusstlos geworden—befand ich mich im Keller. Dieser Keller war eine Eichrichtung dieses Lager Ältesten, dieser BVer—Berufsverbrecher. Der Keller stand etwa brusthoch unter Wasser. Im Wasser selbst haben damals, als ich ein kam etwa neunzig (90) oder fünf und neunzig (95) Menschen gelegen und gestanden.
David Boder: Die konnten doch nicht liegen?
Jaques Matzner: Gelegen, diejenigen, die gelegen haben, die waren schon tot. Und diejenigen, die gestanden haben, haben die Leichen der Toten sich so zurecht gelegt, dass sie darauf sitzen konnten, sonst wären die noch Lebenden auch schon ertrunken gewesen. Ich habe das Selbe getan. Ich habe mir einen Platz an der Wand heraus gefunden, ich habe ein oder zwei (2) Leichen, die schon im Wasser lagen, unter dem Wasser zurecht geschleppt an die Wand und ich habe mich darauf gesetzt. Und so habe ich im Wasser gelegen, von diesem Morgen an gerechnet zwei (2) Tage und zwei (2) Nächte. Während dieser Zeit ist ertrunken im Wasser mein Kamerad, der neben mir lag, Ludwig Pasternak, aus Ungarn, der mich immer gebeten hat „Matzner“, sagte er zu mir „Matzner, wenn ich nicht gerettet werde, dann sag Du meinem Cousin, der in Toulouse lebt, dass ich gestorben bin und dass mein letzter Gedanke mein Vater, meine Mutter und meine Geschwister gewesen sind. Sag meinem Cousin Jenö Hillmann, dass ich’s nicht mehr überleben konnte.“ Dieser Jenö Hillmann war auch im gleichen Lager.
David Boder: Wie war der Name?
Jaques Matzner: Jenö, Jenö Hillmann. Und so ist mein Freund Ludwig Pasternak gestorben. Ich glaube ein Verwandter von ihm, war auch dieser berühmte französische Opernsänger Louis Pasteur. Und dann kam es auf einmal so, ich weiß es ja selbst nicht, wie es war—ich war ja diese Tage und diese Nächte wie benommen, ich habe nur mehr instinktiv geatmet, ich habe nur mehr instinktiv gelebt. Ich habe nichts mehr gegessen und nichts mehr getrunken, aber ich habe noch gelebt. Und dann hat es auf einmal geheißen: „Alles raus! Raus!“ und dann kamen Menschen von oben und ich befand mich auf einmal wieder in einem Zimmer. Und da war kein Wasser und ich habe am Boden gelegen und nachher auf einem Tisch gelegen. Und dann stand wieder mein Freund Fischel Wiener vor mir und der hat nur zu mir gesagt: „Matzner, Du wirst leben, Du wirst leben. Nach Haus geht’s ja doch! Und Du wirst stark und Du wirst leben! Die Russen sind schon vor den Türen, die Russen kimmen.“ Und dann weiß ich, dass ich tatsächlich in einem richtigen Bett gelegen hab, wo alles weiß gewesen ist und dann war es Nacht. Und da kam zu mir ein Mann, der streichelte mir den Kopf und ich erkannte nur noch eine Uniform in der gleichen Farbe wie sie die amerikanischen Soldaten tragen. Und er streichelte mir über den Kopf und er sprach zum mir, aber ich verstand ihn nicht. Dann rief er eine Krankenschwester, die war in weiß. Ich habe ja nicht gewusst, dass er eine Krankenschwester ruft. Ich hab nur gewusst, dass er eine Krankenschwester gerufen hat, nachdem diese da war. Sie hatte ein weißes Tuch über dem Kopf und sie sprach russisch. Und er sprach mit ihr irgend etwas und kam nach einer Zeit zurück mit zwei (2) Flaschen. Und diese beiden Flaschen hat er über mich ausgegossen und hat mich damit gewaschen. Es war Cognac. Heute weiß ich, dass es Whiskey war oder Cognac. Damals wusste ich es nicht, es hat mich nur wunderbar erfrischt.
David Boder: Er hat sie gewaschen damit?
Jaques Matzner: Er hat mich damit gewaschen. Er hat die Bettdecke zurück geschlagen und hat mich damit gewaschen. Die Schwester hat so ein Gummituch unter mich gelegt und er hat mich mit dem Whisky oder mit dem Cognac von oben bis unten gewaschen, es hat mich wunderbar erfrischt. Neben mir—in dem Bett nebenan—lag ein griechischer Rechtsanwalt. Er hieß—ich weiß nicht..., ich glaube er hieß Nissin, ich habe ihn nur Nissin gerufen. Er sagte zu...er hat dauernd gerufen: „Adonai, adonai, adonai, Matzner, das ist gut, das ist gut. Ça, c’est bien.“ Er hat französisch gesprochen. „Ça, c’est bien. Ça, c’est bien pour vous. Ça, c’est bien a votre vie. Ça, c’est bien.” Und ich kam dann auch tatsächlich zu mir und ich kam dann auch in Behandlung eines russischen Arztes, sein Name ist mir entfallen. Jedenfalls ich machte damals noch einen sehr starken Typhus mit.
David Boder: Flecktyphus oder...?
Jaques Matzner: Einen Bauchtyphus. Ich wurde in Behandlung dieses russischen Arztes—ich wurde wirklich wunderbar behandelt—ich bin gesundet. Aus diesem russischen Spital kam ich nachher in das internationale Lager, wo wir von (Name unverständlich)...
Jaques Matzner: . . . ein amerikanischer Pilot hat Hemden und Wäschestücke, Schokolade und Grapefruit und Essen und Trinken geschenkt bekamen und wir haben immer nur gesprochen...unsere Leute haben immer nur gesprochen, das eine Wort: OK, OK, OK. Es waren ja alles Ungarn und Griechen und so weiter, die kein Englisch kannten und die haben nur gewusst OK, OK. Heute weiß ich, dass es damals amerikanische Soldaten gewesen sind. Und ich kam dann nachher in das französische Hospital, dort gab ich mich als Franzose aus, damit ich nach Frankreich transportiert werde. Ich wollte nicht...
David Boder: Sprechen Sie französisch?
Jaques Matzner: Ich spreche gut französisch, denn ich habe ja eine Zeitlang in Frankreich gelebt. Ich habe mich als Franzose aus gegeben, dieser kleine Trick ist mir gelungen und ich kam mit dem letzten französischen Transport nach Bad Schwartau, dort wurde ich aufgenommen in ein Lager der englischen Armee, wo ich den ersten uniformierten Juden traf. Das war ein gewisser Henry...Harry Dumbrand aus London, also jedenfalls aus England. Er hat mich beschenkt mit Zigaretten, er hat sich gefreut, dass er einen Juden gesehen hat und erst mal wieder trifft. Und von Bad Schwartau aus, kam ich in ein UNRRA Lager in Geldern, das ist in der Nähe von Kevelaer an der holländischen Grenze. Und von dort aus kam ich in meine Heimatstadt Wiesbaden. Es zog mich nach Wiesbaden, erstens mal, weil es mein Geburtsort ist und weil ich glaubte, dass von hier ich aus die ersten Recherchen nach meiner Familie beginnen kann und dann, weil es die amerikanische Zone war. Ich kam nach Wiesbaden zurück und ich war noch sehr krank und sehr schwach und ich verbrachte hier durch die Hilfe amerikanischer Freunde, die ich hier kennenlernte, insbesondere Captain Dave LeMelman aus Miami, der sich meiner ganz besonders angenommen hat.
David Boder: Wie heißt er?
Jaques Matzner: Captain Dave LeMelman, er ist ein Jude und stammt aus Miami.
David Boder: Miami?
Jaques Matzner: Miami, der sich meiner ganz besonders angenommen hat. Dann ausserdem noch ein Second Lieutenant Lori Hundell aus New York und noch verschiedene Andere, nicht zu vergessen: Einer—ein amerikanischer Offizier, der nachher zu meinen besten Freunden zählte, Mr. Harald Wilk, aus New York, ein Jude, alles nur Juden. Und “last not least“ die Krone meiner Bekanntschaften, das war dieser wunderbare Mensch Chaplain William Ted Darling, ein Mensch, der sich nicht nur mir persönlich, sondern der ganzen jüdischen Gemeinde Wiesbaden derart angenommen hat, dass ich als Wiesbadener die Inspiration erhalten habe, das Gotteshaus, das meinen Eltern und dem ältesten Rabbiner Deutschlands, Rabbiner Dr. Leo Kahn [unverständlich; hebräisch], als heilige Stätte gedient hat, wieder aufzubauen. Ich betrachte es fast als meine Lebensaufgabe dieses Haus in dem mein Vater und meine Mutter [unverständlich; hebräisch], dieses Haus, in dem ich Bar Mitzvah’d geworden bin, dieses Haus in dem meine Schwestern und meine Brüder Jahrzehnte lang ihren Gottesdienst verrichtet haben, wieder so aufzubauen, wie es gewesen ist. Ich betrachte es als meine Lebensaufgabe den Toten und denen, die nicht mehr wiederkehren und denen, die rechtzeitig dieses Land verlassen konnten, eine Stätte zu errichten von der aus das Wort Gottes in die ganze Welt gehen soll. Als eine Stätte zum Gedenken an alle die Menschen, die einstmals Wiesbaden kannten und die einstmals in Wiesbaden waren. Ich betrachte dies weiter als eine meiner größten Aufgaben so lange noch Juden in Deutschland—in der amerikanischen Zone und in Wiesbaden sein werden, ein jüdisches Leben zu errichten, kulturell, religiös, caritativ und in jeder Hinsicht zur Förderung für die Immigration nach Israel und nach allen Juden-Staaten in die die einzelnen Personen hin wollen. Der Grossteil unserer Gemeinde setzt sich zusammen aus [unverständlich] Personen, die aus den Konzentrationslagern entlassen wurden und die hier in Wiesbaden jetzt wieder eine Heimstätte gefunden haben. Ich selbst gehöre zum Vorstand der jetzt gegründeten jüdischen Gemeinde in Wiesbaden. Ich sehe mein ganzes Können, mein ganzes Wollen, meinen ganzen Willen und auch meine ganze Aufgabe darin, das zu tun, was den Leuten zum Guten sein soll. Und wenn es mir erstattet ist an dieser Stelle zu sagen, dass ich insbesondere in A G T vertreten, durch die leider zu früh abgereisten Miss Patty Tender, meinen Dank aussprechen möchte. Ebenso dem ehemals hier stationierten Chaplin Vidar Goldstein, und so weiter. Dann möchte ich meinen besonderen Dank aussprechen dem Vertreter von Joint, Mr. Lakso—Mr. Kowalznik, der sich jetzt wahrscheinlich in Schanghai befinden wird. Und wenn es mir noch gestattet ist meine Freunde von hier aus zu grüßen- Mr. Darril und Else Steinlau in New York, Mrs. und Mr. Hedwig Meier in Chicago, Mr. And Mrs. Rainier Blum in Chicago und alle meine Freunde, die meinen Namen bestimmt gut kennen. Die Freunde, die früher hier in Wiesbaden gewesen sind, die mich bestimmt nicht vergessen haben., denn ich heiße noch so, wie ich früher geheißen habe, Jaques Matzner, und ich wünsche anlässlich dieser Feiertage allen meinen Freunden in der ganzen Welt, wo sie auch sein mögen, [unverständlich; Tonband rauschen] wunderbare...Professor Boder aus Chicago, durch den mir die Möglichkeit gegeben ist, alle meine Freunde der jüdischen Gemeinde in der ganzen Welt zu grüßen und ihnen ein „meschono [unverständlich; hebräisch] zuzurufen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes a report—rather condensed—of Mr. Jack Matzner. There would be a number of questions I would like to ask him and he could probably give me some very intelligent answers, but since it could be done by mail, I think I will call in one and the other of the two ladies who are waiting for the interview. It’s a very difficult thing to have...to stagger the interviewees—you don’t want to interrupt, it takes always more times than you expect. We are now going over to the next interview [unintelligible] start Mr. Matzner at twenty-five minutes of Spool 164.
David Boder: This concludes Spool 9-164A—the interview with Jack Matzner. The second part—the interview with Anna Kovitzka—is put on separate spool, 164B. The 14th of November, 1950, Boder.